I got last night or anything that I
might be able to entertainment tonight
Daniel it's funny people bring you
snacks and at concerts for performers
from the most part people bring them
weed and rods really it's a little
different dude I'm so much and it's so
much more practical for me that was in
bronze I don't do either of those
actually Thanks you do eat snacks
um so back saving the the galaxy again
yeah did it again that back at it again
man yeah like like rocket said two-time
galaxy sabers now we can really jack up
on prices how is it to be back with her
on it I mean it seemed like you guys
didn't this would be dude it felt that
way it's so great it was so great to be
back it's so it's so awesome to be out
selling this movie talking about this
movie were all so proud of it we love
each other we're a family well that's
Kurt actually said he us didn't really
like each other and I was only if you
knew you disliked him as quickly as he
knew he disliked you he just said he'd
said in Italy I said he would actually
set often and you would leave you would
just leave is that why he did that
yeah I thought I just needed this yeah
yeah so did you realize was quickly
alien like him immediately I knew
immediately that he would be like oh
yeah man he's he's the best he's such a
he's such a good dude we have a lot in
common we had we had a lot to talk about
even outside of Hollywood and you know I
had my probably 10 15 minutes of like
geeking out like a fan a turned into
like just us being peers and talking
about our common interests and things
that we liked and you know there were a
lot we got a lot we we got along really
well does he push in you you when you
when you're a consumer like that you
look up to and you have that dynamic oh
yeah yeah there was a great time there
was a great thing that happened where
like because we're did a lot of stunt
work and it's moving a lot of wire work
Wow really uncomfortable stuff to do and
you know I've always pride myself on
being tough I mean like I can do this
but he was comforting me and there were
moments where I was like okay I need to
we need to pull the plug on this thing
it's I'm hurting I can't do and I look
at him he's doing he's like yeah I got
another one at me if you want
I can't I think like we so we did maybe
we pushed each other maybe he was trying
to run out to him but the result was
both of us were walking a little funny
but we can amazing and some amazing some
amazing yeah yeah really good see um
having said that you have an interesting
dynamic in the movie with with your
father what was your relationship like
with your father growing up my father
yeah oh wow um you know I had my
father's a great father he was very much
a presence in my life he was always
there he was my coach of my sports teams
he was a tough man yes he was strict and
commanded my respect he's a man of few
words the kind of guy who if he said he
was going to do something he was going
to he would do it and yeah he-he's very
much shaped the person I ended up I
turned out to be yeah and yeah so are
you becoming your dad you find in
certain ways yeah certain ways yes and
in certain ways no I think like you know
I think it's a responsibility as a man
who becomes a father is to to determine
the father they're going to be and
oftentimes that is based on the
influences they've had both positive and
negative like you see what worked for
free free and what didn't work you know
so you make certain choices and
commitments like yeah I'm gonna do that
because that's how my dad did it he also
might say I'm not going to do that
because that's how my dad did it you
know and so like walking that fine line
and understanding you know like praying
for the wisdom to know the difference
between what you are going to do what
you're not going to do based on the
influence that your father had on you is
is something that I'm kind of dealing
with every day
is there a funny quirky thing that you
like to avoid that maybe your dad did
something little more lighthearted you
know my dad was was really funny yeah
and uh and uh so but he also liked and
it's like I catch myself doing this now
I'm trying I'm trying to make sure that
my my humor isn't like a cutting kind of
humor because that's the kind of stuff I
love but I have to remember that it but
sometimes people if they don't get it
you can hurt their feelings like it's
important to be considerate of people's
feelings but but that's the thing I
struggle with I'm like but is it
important to be considerate of feelings
because maybe I became the guy I am I
have really thick skin it's soup
hard to hurt my beloved out because I
got toughened up yeah so like that's the
fine balance like I'm gonna try to tough
my kid up but I don't find the hard for
it like the minute I say something tough
and he cries a little I hope you so much
I just told me